all right guys welcome back uh in this
video let's talk about what do you
really need to succeed in Pak farming
what are the things you really need to
succeed in Peak farming this is uh a
very important uh video a very important
content I would like you to pay
attention to uh so that you would be
able to U make the right profit from
your farm now if you're new to this
channel quickly subscribe to this
channel it takes you nothing it cost you
nothing quickly subscribe for great
content on profitable P farm and several
other agricultural ventur
now uh what does it take for you to
succeed in Peak farming the general
answer to the mind of U people that are
not very much uh knowledgeable on how uh
animal vandry is being run probably they
are very much ignorant the very
important answer or ignorant answer
rather that many people will give you is
money the answer will be money the money
is what you need for you to be
successful in farming in Peak farming or
in any other animal husbandry well as as
much as this is partially true you need
money to run lots of great things on
your farm but it's not absolutely true
you can literally have enough money
sufficient money abundant money and
still not succeed in Pak farming and in
any other agricultural
Venture now the question then is what
exactly do you need to succeed in Pak
farming what do you really need uh if
money is not the answer which I can
literally prove that to you because uh
if you check the internet I'm sure I
could probably if you need it I could
probably show you the video uh snow
farming for instance I I already told
you guys that um uh I have I have
experience when it comes to snail
farming and I'll bringing videos and
content on snail far s farming very soon
and and several other agricultural uh
Ventures because I've doubled and I've
delved into several of them I was
successful in almost all of them now in
there's a video online that I like Ed a
farmer that spent I think about 8
million or there when I got to research
on it or something about 8 million in
building is new pen 8 million and the
farm was failing 8 million NRA and the
farm was failing this is very clear if
money was what it takes for you to uh be
successful in farming or in any other
animal H bandry then that guy that
person should be making it because 8
million is quite a number of a H amount
of money now and this young man right
here talking to you did not even spend
I'm not sure I spent up to 100,000 you
know I literally if you if when I I walk
you through the story very soon but I
remember building a small um a one of
the pen for about 30,000 one of the pens
I build and some other of course I buil
some other ones and I was making it
greatly when it comes to snail farming I
had lots of snails I had abundant snails
it was so much that the issue was space
I told you already in a previous video
that the issue I always had when it
comes to animaland in many cases was
space space was the issue getting enough
space to run the farm
so I was able to run through snow
farming without the number of cash that
person had telling you already that of
course I needed cash to do something
that's why you can't rule out money when
it comes to succeeding in animal laundry
but it's not everything you need what
you really need are some of the things
I'll be mentioning in this video all
right one of the things you need is
building great relationship you need to
build great relationship many of you
will not understand what I'm saying
until when you get into it then you
understand that you alone can't run it a
farm is not successful on your energy
your Manpower alone you need people you
need a great uh support system you need
to have a great support system and when
I say support system I don't mean people
funding you money all this that's not
what I mean here I mean support when it
comes to
getting your resources getting your farm
resources laboring on your farm and
every other thing for instance now I'm
sure you have you have watched uh some
of our videos when it comes to feed and
everything one of the ingredient we use
for our feeds on the farm right here is
got from the Breaky it's got from the
Breaky and uh there's a lot of competion
for it cuz it's not uh in abundance it's
not like it's so much available or
something so how are we able to get from
them
uh to get the waste from there it's
relationship right there in the bakery I
have a great relationship with somebody
right there there's an importance of
relationship in everything you do you
may not understand until you get into it
and if you don't build the right
relationship it will literally affect
you it affect your profit you affect
your cost because what you would do for
lesser amount you will do it for much
more amount and I have a worker right
now very faithful and very honest and
the relationship I have with him is so
in is so much great that I can depend on
him for several activities when it comes
to my farm that's some of the things you
want to do you want to have great
relationship with several both the
people that you're getting resources
from and people that working for you
want to have great relationship with
them you don't want to be uh alone you
can't stand alone when it comes to
farming now that's just one of them some
other things you need is tenacity you
need tenacity you need consistency I
want you to know that it's not going to
be Rosy all the time it's never Rosy for
anyone all the time time there's nobody
anybody that deceives you that tells you
that he's having it 100% perfect when it
comes to farming is lying to you it's
not always Rosy there are several things
you're going to go through several
experiences that are home for sinen some
things you will not even expect that
even The Best of the Best of the Best of
the experienced people will still have
issues with it I was I heard a farmer
this farmer I'm sure when it comes to
experience this farmer will DWF me when
it comes to experience he has been in
pig farming for quite a very long time
now but right on his farm he had issues
with uh this thing we call the soja hunt
that's the I don't know if it's called
soja HT in every place but the this ants
that are very dangerous they they walk
in colonies and they are very they when
they bombard the farm they bombard very
in numbers now this U man's Pig gave
birth to I think not less than eight
eight pigl or so and this so Devo all
the animals they finished they literally
finished all the animals they H all the
animals this are not these are not
challenges that you're going to wake up
and think you're going to face but
obviously he faced it so you that's why
I say you need tenacity and consistency
you need that strength within it's not
just all about the videos you watch
online you need to understand that
everything you watch online is a summary
of all that go that people put in when
it comes to farming what you really need
what really goes on they don't show you
and that's why I'm telling you right
here you need 10 you're going to face
challenges that it's only that
resolve that resoluteness Within that's
going to take you through and that's why
I'm telling you right now when you
preparing to get or you eat already and
getting discour you're facing challenge
or the other all you need to do is to
stay Resolute keep on keeping on you
don't need to back down you don't need
to back down face your challenges
squarely find solutions to them make the
right decisions and you'll come true
you'll come true you have to be decisive
that's another thing you need to also
have DEC decisiveness it's very
important for you to make the right
decisions and this is why I've
emphasized on you amassing knowledge
Consulting watching videos watch our
videos watch our content you need to
because those decisions you're going to
make are going to be from a world of
knowledge before I got into Pig farming
before I even dabbled into Pig farming
the knowledge I had in pig farming was
so great I didn't knew so much already
so before you even think about dabbing
into it why don't you watch lots of
videos read lots of books understand
lots of things and don't focus on just
the success story focus on the
challenges people face try and
understand the things and foresee the
things have foresight on the things that
you are going to face also but by the
way no matter how much you watch or how
much you read you're going to face
things that are going to meet you on aw
I want you to know that but at least you
can mitigate the risk that comes with it
by learning ahead so you have to be
decisive you have to make the right
decisions those decisions are not going
to be made made by other people in your
F you have to be you are the you're the
owner of your farm you have to be the
one to make the the right decisions so
make sure you have the right knowledge
that's what's going to foil the right
decisions and consult people you have to
have an alliance of people I mean
Farmers that you can easily reach out to
and reach out to what's going on here
what's going on here you know you need
that resource you need that resource uh
you need to be resourceful that's
another thing you need to have you need
to be very resourceful if you're going
to spend money on everything you're
going to run at a loss or probably just
break even you're not going to be able
to make massive profit you need to be
resourceful you need to be resourceful
in things you do if you have the money
still be resourceful it it's not the
money you don't need to expend your
money all the time be resourceful find a
way to get things done cheaper and in a
much more creative
way don't spend money all the
time and uh last but not the least I'll
be mentioning here amongst others there
are others obviously to talk about but
just to keep it short you have to
pray for good luck you have to pray for
good luck there are certain things that
could happen that no matter how much you
do you know there's this thing they call
the swine fever swine fever is extremely
deadly extremely deadly you have to pray
and you have to hope you have to you
have to pray for good luck you have to
pray that you don't employ the a farm
worker that will kill all your animals
those are some of the things that you
don't you you you you can't read in a
book or watch in a video they are
terrible people I've seen what Farm
Workers do on on certain Farms you have
to put checks and balances on your Farm
Workers as much as you want to if you
have to run a c or whatever you have to
do I've seen Farm Workers that will bury
HS inside the sand of porry farms those
are Farm Workers there are Farm Workers
that would I think I've seen some that
probably kill maybe this are te also I
don't know but there are lots of things
that happen what about the why I say you
have to pray for good luck what about
tips those are things that you no matter
what about th that connive with the
security people those are things that
you can't you can't uh foresee and
that's why you have to just hope for
good luck hope in God and pray for good
luck so all right guys that will be all
for this video These are some of the
things you really need apart from money
apart from Land apart from structures
and all those things apart from feeds
which obviously still come with money
these are some of the things you need be
very successful in pig from I really
hope this has helped you I hope you're
motivated I hope you're inspired and I
hope this will go a long way in ensuring
that you're able to make the right
profit on your farm and if you're new to
this channel if you're yet to subscribe
please make sure you subscribe it's so
free it comes at no cost it cost you
nothing subscribe to this Channel and
click on the Bell icon so you get
notified each time we drop a video all
right guys that'll be all for today
thank you very much bye-bye